the day after inauguration you get a
phone call and it's Edward Snowden
saying alright I'm ready to come back
what he gone there you know I think
justice is about making punishment
proportional to the crime and I think
his intentions were to reveal something
that he felt like the people in
government were lying about and it turns
out they were lying the Director of
National Intelligence committed perjury
in front of the Senate committee my
understanding is it's about a five year
sentence but instead of getting any kind
of sentence said I'm getting a slap on
the wrist or instead of even being fired
he's been rewarded and he's still in
charge of intelligence and I think he's
done a great deal to damaged trust on
the other side of the coin
can you let people who have sensitive
data just make the decision to reveal it
to the world I think you have to have
laws against that so I think there have
to be laws against what Snowden did did
he do it for a higher purpose does he
have a high moral ground all of that I
think history will judge but I've sort
of tongue-in-cheek said that if I had
the choice I'd put clapper and Stoughton
in the same jail cell for about the same
period of time now that's not a serious
question but I think it would be an
interesting debate they might have about
you know Liberty versus security I guess
the question is what you have put a
microphone in there I know but they
probably could have a reality jail-cell
show and then probably you know
bestseller no I think that there has to
be some punishment what that is but I
think the other side's been crazy over
the top that people say they want to
shoot Snowden or they want to hang him
or that you know I think that one of the
things that we've tried to promote is a
reform that would make things different
Snowden has said he would have tried
official channels to reveal this to
someone officially but that the
whistleblower statute doesn't apply to
contractors so I actually have an
amendment that would try to make that so
so if you're a contractor doing business
with the intelligence agency and you
find that they're breaking the law and
interestingly the courts have now said
the NSA is breaking the law it's my
other pet peeve with the president on
this whole thing president says Oh will
you know he accuses me of getting in the
way of performance like you could have
stopped the program anytime you wanted
you did it through executive or
you're doing it through executive action
we never told you to do this program in
fact even the authors of the Patriot Act
say they never intended to give you this
power and yet you won't stop it until we
actually affirmative ly tell you to stop
it so I think the president's not quite
sincere you know in wanting real reform